foreign
[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
Terror now as I mentioned in my last
book review about literally dead I am a
sucker for a good Halloween Horror
Anthology whether it's in book or film
form I like both of those things uh the
one I'm talking about today which is
called This is Halloween by James a
Moore is a little bit different than the
last one I talked about uh because this
one is actually 10 mostly Halloween
themed stories by a single author rather
than you know being a bunch of various
authors and several of these stories as
well are interconnected uh this book is
actually I found it on Kindle unlimited
it's actually slightly older than I
realized um you know when I first
checked it out or whatever it was
actually first published in 2016. so not
that old but I was just like thinking
that it came out this year now I read
that some of the stories that are
included in this collection Link in with
some of James Amor's many novels but I'm
not entirely sure sure about that and
I'm not entirely sure like which ones I
think this is the first work of his that
I've read and again this seems to be
like another a case of another author
who's been around for like ages he's
been writing novels and he writes like a
lot of RPG manuals like since the mid
1990s I think he first published in 1994
and somehow I'm just discovering him now
so you know better late than never I
guess now while a few of these 10
stories were not directly Halloween
related all of them did kind of have a
very similar like autumnal vibe to them
and they did kind of you know to greater
or lesser degrees uh evoke that kind of
very specifically very frosty nostalgic
New England kind of feel that always
kind of puts me right in the Halloween
spirit even though you know if you guys
know me you know I live in Florida so I
don't ever get to experience a chili
Halloween firsthand unfortunately maybe
someday I'll live somewhere that has
actual seasons and I can actually do
that [ __ ] but uh you know for one of
these days one of these days it'll
happen so uh some of these Tales too
like tapped into a larger mythology
about a place called Bell Dam woods and
an ancient witch and her three sons like
they were kind of like Earth's but I
don't want to say if they were like
Earth Spirits or like demons or
something like that but it's like a
witch and three sons and they're like
Supernatural and uh also several of them
had a similar setup of like a group of
kids trick-or-treating and being chased
and or attacked by something
Supernatural so I will say that because
of that a couple of the stories came
across as a little bit samey but I
didn't really mind it all that much um I
just kind of like read the whole book
like approached it as you know just kind
of like a collection of creepy
narratives about different people that
were sort of like taking place all
around the same town like around the
same time even though technically I
think they weren't but it does it did
kind of have that vibe to it so the
first story the dry season is one of
these aforementioned trick-or-treating
stories there's a pair of women named
Linda and Nancy and they're taking their
kids and some other of the neighborhood
kids like just out on the rounds like
doing trick-or-treating like you do now
they start to feel as though they're
being followed or watched or something
and they're also kind of like um you
know their discussion is sort of about
how creeped out they are by the fact
that this house that had been empty for
many years like in the neighborhood um
after this guy named Martin Lundgren
supposedly killed a bunch of children
there now appears to be occupied like it
has somebody living in it now as The
Story Goes On you discover that maybe
the town rumors about what really
happened regarding the murders of those
children uh weren't what everyone
thought and that's about as far as I'm
gonna go with that one now the second
story was actually one of the best ones
in the collection in my opinion uh it's
called Harvest Moon and it's about a
widower who moves from Los Angeles to a
quaint little town I think it's in new
New England called Summitville like
after he retires now he actually loves
the place at first he's like it's like
the picture the perfect like picture
postcard like New England Halloween kind
of thing he actually like ends up
finding romance with like another like
Local woman named Helen and he even
befriends his grumpy But ultimately
good-hearted like elderly neighbor whose
name is Ned as Halloween approaches
though uh the narrator begins to become
a little bit unsettled by
um just how into Halloween everyone in
this town seems to be and in particular
they're kind of like obsessive tradition
of building these really really creepy
scarecrows and positioning all of them
in the Town Square like facing inward uh
this one had like a really good cool
like old school Pagan kind of ambiance
to it which I really really dug so the
third story was called hathburn Avenue
and it was very similar to the first
story in that it revolved around a group
of kids who were trick-or-treating and
came across a house that wasn't right
somehow you know what I mean this one is
actually told not from the point of view
of the parents like the first one was
but from the POV of one of the kids
um who's talking about how one of his
friends named Chuck recently died in a
house fire that also like claimed the
rest of his family as well
um so as the narrator and his little
friends or whatever are kind of trooping
around the neighborhood they come across
this house like on a street they don't
usually go on that looks um very
unsettlingly like the one that burned
down not too long ago
um so yeah this was like a really good
evocative story as well although as I
mentioned it's very similar in setup
um to the first story and I've actually
kind of been payoff too so much so that
while I was researching this review like
while I was writing uh the review I
actually got them confused with one
another for a bit and like thought that
the first story like had the house fire
aspect in this one but yeah it's two
different stories so the fourth one is
called bone Harvest and this was one of
the ones that tied in with this larger
lore about beldam woods and though it
wasn't really halloween-centric it was
still like a pretty cool concept it was
about there was like a couple of I guess
like botanists or Botanical enthusiasts
if you want to call them that uh their
names were Reggie and Natalie and they
go on a vacation in these supposedly
Haunted Woods
um because the area is home to a number
of very very rare plants that are found
nowhere else in the world almost all of
which are deadly poisonous now at some
point during this excursion uh Natalie
gets attacked that's all I'm gonna say
and then like eventually the
supernatural comes into play and so this
story sort of delves into this Mythos
that James Amor created about this
ancient witch named Alvina Bathory and
her three sons now the sun featured in
this particular story is actually named
Robert or better known as old bones I
really liked the imagery and the gore in
this one this one's like pretty gory
though I think I would have preferred
more of like a Halloween Focus but
that's okay this like this was like a
pretty cool story too now the next story
Harvest Gods Revisited was also pretty
great uh and this was another one of the
interconnected stories but was a lot
more Halloween forward so this one is
actually told from the perspective of a
Halloween loving little boy named Ray
whose dad actually died sometime
previously and he's now been kind of
like bummed out dispirited Whatever by
this boyfriend that his mom is going
around with who's a very kind of like
fun averse and just generally shitty
human being
so the story is basically just Rey
um you know trying to like leaving
school on Halloween and trying to take a
shortcut to get home quicker so he can
like get ready and go out
trick-or-treating because he's super
excited but he's never taken the
shortcut before and it gets lost and he
runs into another one of the witch's
Sons whose name is Jack and he ends up
making a bargain with this son uh that
has that ties back in with his kind of
like less than ideal living situation so
I think this was another one of my
favorites in the collection it was very
simple very short very sweet and it just
had like a really cool like Halloween
mood to it now the next story Patchwork
was about the third of the witch's Sons
whose name is Patrick now I think this
was probably in the whole collection
this is probably my least favorite
um it might have been the longest I mean
it's still not all that long it's still
I don't even know if I'd call it like
Novella length although it might have
been
um but it was really complex like it
jumped back and forth between several
different characters and there was like
a bunch of things going on on in spite
of the relative brevity of the story as
a whole so it's basically about Patrick
pretending to be a human and also kind
of like trying to please his mother
through various sacrifices and the main
story about Patrick is just mostly about
him like having a job delivering milk
and stuff for a dairy along with another
guy named Denny who's kind of a
pedophile like kind of a creeper like so
there's that going on then also there's
like a parallel plot about a group of
girls like a bunch of school girls
planning to bully this new girl who's
just moved a town named Erica like
essentially by taking her into these
cursed Woods you know that we've
mentioned before and making her think
that they were forcing her to eat one of
the poisonous mushrooms and then there
was another thing like another kind of
like plot thing over here about a woman
named Lacey whose baby had died and she
had a husband who beat her and possibly
molested her daughters and I can't
really remember how that tied into the
main plot like I'm pretty sure that it
did but I can't remember right now like
how it did so like overall this was a
good story too I just felt like it was
kind of like all over the place
um it was way too convoluted for as
relatively short as it was all the plot
tendrils it had going on I think would
have been better in novel form like
where everything could have been fleshed
out more it's possible like I said that
this one was referring back to some
larger Mythos that he had like laid out
in another book it did definitely have
that feel to it now the next story Night
Eyes was written with Charles R Rutledge
and was another one concerning a group
of kids these ones actually they
specifically said it was Georgia in 1973
uh who were kind of out and about on
Halloween night so they're actually
trying to avoid a family of bullies that
one of them had pissed off earlier so
they decide to go trick-or-treat at the
old Grambling place which is supposedly
the home of this creepy old man where
nobody goes things don't go the way you
think they do uh this one was also
really good in Halloween but again kind
of similar to the previous two that I
mentioned that were about kids going
trick-or-treating and like going to a
house they shouldn't essentially so the
next one was called blood tide and that
was another one with not seemingly not
much to do with Halloween but it told
the story of a I guess like a
supernatural being of some kind whose
name was like Jason Solis and he at the
beginning he buys a property from
another character who is also kind of
like a supernatural being I feel like
named Albert miles who was featured in a
couple of the earlier stories now Solis
says that he wants a girl for some
implied purpose and then we start to
follow said girl uh who is actually like
a sex worker uh like a higher end escort
named Maggie and she ends up getting
stalked by a couple of dudes who are
like going to Rob and rape her uh this
was again like another good story though
I admit just like the last story that it
felt like it was a fragment a fragment
of some like larger narrative and I
didn't really get exactly like what the
connection was between the soulless
character and what was happening with
Maggie's character because it seemed
like there was like this book ending of
like these supposedly I thought like it
was implied that they were like
supernatural beings of some kind and
that they wanted her for something but
then like the middle part was almost
like a thriller like that was kind of
grounded in reality so I didn't really
get what the connection was between
those two things now the penultimate
story Shades of Gray was another one of
my favorite ones even though again it
wasn't particularly Halloweeny but that
was okay like um you know I really
really like this one a lot so this one
was actually told from the POV of a
private investigator named Neil and at
the beginning of the story he overhears
someone telling someone else that
something is following them now
thereafter the person who was being
followed turns up dead like in a
gruesome way and Neil sort of gets
intrigued enough to begin conducting his
own investigation into whatever it is
that's following and perhaps murdering
these people and specifically whether
it's human or not like he also kind of
gets his brother involved he's a
photographer so there's that kind of
stuff going on this one had a really
compelling like Noir kind of feel to it
and that made it like really appealing
to me even though it wasn't like very
halloween-centric so the last story The
Walker Place uh was the fourth story in
the collection that centered around a
group of kids on Halloween this time out
they end up going to another notorious
house in town but this time the house uh
the whole like a whole family was
brutally murdered in there and the kids
go in there and perhaps unwisely end up
using a Ouija board to contact some
Spirits which you know you you've seen
the shows it's never a good idea to do
that uh so yeah so this wasn't like the
most original tale but it was still like
pretty creepy and also like really
entertaining good kind of like short way
to close the book out so although the
stories I mean all the stories here are
not explicitly like Halloween based
there was enough of that vibe to make
this a really good read for you know
October October for the spooky season
some of the stories as I mentioned seem
a little bit fragmentary as though they
were referencing other longer stories
like outside the scope of this book
which I believe some of them were if I'm
reading some of the reviews correctly
um that's not necessarily a deal breaker
you can still understand what's going on
in the stories even if you haven't read
the other novels that they're supposedly
referring to but I think if you had read
some other works of his that linked back
to this maybe you would get more out of
it you'd there'd be more like you know
there'd be more depth to it for you
because you would know like a lot more
about the Mythos and about these
characters and stuff like that also uh
as I mentioned a handful of the stories
four of them I believe you know are kind
of similar in the sense that they all
involve a group of kids or a group of
people like trick-or-treating and like
going to a house they shouldn't or
something chasing them or something in
attacking them so and they were you know
I'm not gonna lie they were so similar
that I mixed up the details like from a
few of them especially like the first
one on the third one so but you know
like I said it didn't really bother me
all that much because they just conjured
such a great uh mood that was like
really effective and really spooky so it
didn't really bother me that they were
kind of all similar stories so all in
all I thought this was like a very
strong collection of stories that had
you know enough of that vintage
Halloween atmosphere to put you in that
proper frame of mind for the best day of
the year so that will do it for this
tomes of Terror and I will see you guys
again on the next one have a very very
safe and very very happy Halloween bye